يصبح التوتر النفسي مشكله حقيقيه حينما
يمنع الانسان من الاسترخاء ويجبره على
ابداء ردود فعل جسديه غير مستحبه للتوتر
اعراض عده يجب ان ننتبه لها ومنها انه قد
يسبب عدم اليقين والغضب كذلك ربما يسبب
التوتر نقصا بالحوافز وصعوبه في التركيز
والتعب الشديد الا التوتر النفسي ايضا قد
يحمل بل يحمل النفس الاكتئاب والقلق وهو
عباره عن نتيجه اساسيه وعرض مهم يجب
الانتباه له في اطار ملاحظه التوتر النفسي
ومخاطره كذلك فان من اعراض التوتر النفسي
التي يجب الانتباه لها الشعور بعدم
الجداره والخوف وهي مشاعر تتعارض مع
القدره على العيش والاستمتاع بالحياه
ويؤكد خبراء صحيون ان الانسان يجب ان يطلب
مساعده في حال كان هذه كانت هذه الضغوط
والتوتر النفسيه عائقا في العمل والحياه
الاجتماعيه والشخصيه لانه ينعكس بشكل سلبي
عليه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
وال الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات